buondì a tutti
beh diciamo che sono una persona
abbastanza fa ci torna non tende o non
dare tanta confidente non parlare molto
se non durante le conferenze mia moglie
dice che o prevalentemente come l'asse
oratoria tre punti il primo criticare
sua sorella mia cognata
il secondo è un po criticare il modo di
vivere di vita di noi italiani sia qui
in italia che all'estero
e il terzo punto è tediarla con
solamente lei con le mie lunghe
traversate polari che faccio quando
capita una volta all'anno
questo è un po quello che lei dice e
soprattutto capita durante i momenti più
che dovrebbero essere più così di
rilassamento quindi magari a pranzo ea
cena
rimane tutto nel gruppone alla fine però
io non vi racconterò ovviamente della
mia vita polare delle mie lunghe
spedizioni ma vi racconterò di un di un
mio non so se definirlo problema o fobia
insomma il rapporto che ho che negli
ultimi anni è diventato molto
confidenziale con l'acqua e il ghiaccio
che per loro modo hanno anche un po
condizionato la mia vita da fanciullo
fino a 45 anni tra due mesi
quest'anno ha fatto un pò vecchiotta
taro per farvi capire
mia mamma quando ero ancora così
fanciullo mi mandava nelle colonie
estive
la colonia pontificia
ecco per capirsi dove veniva gestita
ovviamente non da persone così tra
virgolette normali ma da sé
e ricordo che ovviamente il primo
periodo era quello più più particolare
perché incontrarvi i bambini che non
conoscevi e quindi cercarvi un po di
divertirti come potevi con loro ma
essendo pontificia
tra fare dieci anni nei lagunari e farne
20 giorni in quella colonia è quasi
meglio far dieci anni da lagunare
voglio dire era un regime che alle tre e
mezza anzi all'una e mezza dove andare a
dormire e ti svegliavi le due e mezza
dopo dalle due e mezza forse ti
portavano e spiaggia e se andava bene
verso le quattro e mezza 5 avevi quella
mezz'oretta in un recinto per farti il
bagno nell'acqua
dopodiché in fila fuori dall'acqua e si
tornava dentro in colonia comunque detto
questo ovviamente l'acqua io mi
divertivo con tutti gli altri bambini
finché un bel giorno non andando più
alle colonie estive
diciamo nella mia regione
mia mamma disse bene andiamo a milano
marittima youtube e via al milano
marittima
siamo andati in un bel posto e dovevamo
così avevamo il nostro ombrellone con
il tavolino quello che era il bello era
anche che oltre a questa diciamo questa
spiaggia al mare tutto quando c'era
anche la tavola da surf con la vela io
avevo tipo 11 anni e ovviamente essendo
una persona molto altruista
praticamente il surf l'ho preso io
dall'inizio fino alla fine della vacanza
finché il castigo divino
cosa ha fatto ha fatto sì che un giorno
andava su e giù dal bagno pochi metri
oltre la riva finché un giorno
proviamo andare un po più avanti sondato
fuori tipo un centinaio di metri poco
più e non sapevo più tornare indietro
quindi non vedevo più il fondo
dell'acqua aaron fuori da mia
possibilità di rientro e così pian piano
questo panino con la sua barchetta è
venuto lì mi ha preso per l'orecchio e
tipo scuola pontificia turismo adesso
dalla mamma è definita anche questa
avventura però cosa è successo è
successo che in quel momento ho avuto un
come posso dirvi uno shock da quel
quegli attimi quei minuti che era anche
parecchio lunghi del fatto che non
riuscivo a ritornare indietro e che
avevo il terrore dell'acqua che
ovviamente essendo anche a filo della
tavola da surf cercava un poche parole
quasi di portarli sotto quindi è stato
nella mia diciamo così l'idea del
momento e quindi quello è stato un po un
momento quasi tragico perché da quella
volta praticamente io l'acqua quando
vado al mare con la mia famiglia più di
qua c'è rabbia non esiste che vado
avanti quindi quello è un po il il punto
qua è un nevaio estivo e anche questo lo
riconduco alle siccome abbiamo maira
fissata con le colonie ovviamente prima
al mare e dopo in montagna sempre con le
solite persone voglio dire però erano un
po più tranquille quindi erano più verso
così visionari sul fatto delle
passeggiate montagne a per i bambini che
faceva faceva bene camminare quindi via
benissimo fatalità che anche lì comunque
c'era quella sorta di martellamento che
avevi la tua borraccia dentro la
borraccia ci mettevi una fettina di
limone perché perché a detta dei tecnici
del momento la fettina di limone ti dava
la sensazione di pienezza e quindi non
avevi più voglia di bere acqua stronzata
del tenente grafica scusate la parola
morale della fiaba arrivati su tipo a
metà tragitto c'era la gente veramente
con la lingua fuori che non riusciva a
real finito l'acqua quindi aveva bisogno
di di bere qualcosa e anche le casualità
ci imbattiamo in questo nevaio gigante
sporco ovviamente di detriti
di sassi caduti dalle pareti che però
aveva il diciamo nella parte finale un
entrata una specie di grotta dove si
poteva tranquillamente camminare e c'era
dei vari rivoli di acqua che cadevano e
quindi tutti quanti ci siamo riempiti di
nuovo la borraccia ed è stata una cosa
straordinaria proprio e cioè rimane è
rimasta proprio nel mio nel mio cervello
ecco per capirsi fino adesso che ve lo
sto raccontando è preso un mora che
finché rimarrà qua in terra è fatto sta
che comunque indipendentemente da questo
nevaio ho sempre avuto un legame molto
particolare con la neve e il ghiaccio
mi è sempre piaciuta fin dall'età più
più piccola e fino adesso cioè un
attrazione
oserei dire morbosa verso questo
elemento qua e un po più di diverso qua
mi trovo a sottoguda e sottoguda è un
piccolo paesino a dir tanto 15 case che
si trova poco prima della marmolada la
regina nostra delle dolomiti italiane
sottoguda d'inverno è una cosa terribile
c'è fa un freddo cane e queste due
pareti questa gola con queste due pareti
di roccia che d'estate sono carine
perché vedi un po l'acqua che scende un
po bagnata d'inverno diventa una
cattedrale di ghiaccio più o meno due
dai 23 tiri di corda quindi per farmi
capire una sessantina di metri d'altezza
di ghiaccio e le prime volte che andavo
a scalare a sottoguda avevo sempre quel
quella paura che in qualche maniera
riuscivo a contenere ma quella paura era
dovuta dal fatto che da un momento
all'altro pensavo che il ghiaccio si
sciogliesse quindi da solido tornasse
acqua e quindi avere una fine tragica
che succede e comunque non è che era
proprio un'idea tanto strampalata
effettivamente ogni tanto succede
bisogna fare molta attenzione a questo
però
da quel momento ho deciso che la
trazione veramente che provavo veniva
amplificata sempre di più io avevo
questo questo ghiaccio che il dr lo
sentivo dentro quindi dovevo vedere e
provare qualcosa di diverso qualcosa di
più lungo e più importante nonché le
cascate di ghiaccio non siano importanti
ma qualcosa di immenso e da lì il passo
almeno per quanto mi riguarda è ovvio
che non posso dirlo per tutti è stato
abbastanza facile nel senso che si è
sciolto
ah no almeno qua nel senso che dal
ghiaccio verticale al ghiacciai più
grandi della terra orizzontali sono
stati un passaggio abbastanza non veloce
ma relativamente se vogliamo veloce e
semplice io la mia prima spedizione l'ho
avuto in groenlandia arrivato in
groenlandia a me sembrava quasi di
esserci già stato talmente tanto avevo
letto e studiato su quel quell'ambiente
che è veramente me lo immaginavo e me lo
sono ritrovato proprio così giusto per
farvi capire ad oggi penso che almeno un
4 mila persone se non di più hanno
scalato che con bombole chi senza che
con la bicicletta che con il deltaplano
con tutto quello che ci si può
immaginare l'everest quindi diciamo una
montagna abbastanza battuta anche quelle
altre gli altri 13 8 mila 12 persone
hanno calpestato il suolo lunare 12 4
mila l'everest 12 il la luna è solamente
due persone un norvegese prima e un
inglese dopo sono riusciti a raggiungere
il polo nord geografico da soli senza
aiuti esterni
quindi si capisce anche se sono cose
diciamo diverse l'una dall'altra però le
accomuna all'esplorazione si capisce che
affrontare l'oceano artico è una cosa
oserei dire disumana io quando mi
trovavo in durante una delle mie
traversate nell'oceano quello che mi
veniva in mente di dire ogni tanto e che
divenne anche il demonio ci passa perché
talmente fuori da ogni pensiero che una
persona riesca a stare 52 giorni come ho
fatto io da solo in quella in quelle in
quel territorio che è una cosa che va
veramente oltre il semplice
il semplice la semplice esperienza in
questo caso
lasciatemi passare semplice occorre un
qualcosa in più
poi tanto per ritornare un attimo
indietro lo spessore dell'oceano artico
varia da 0 a 2 3 metri al massimo e
sotto ai per 14 milioni di chilometri
quadrati per farmi capire l'europa ne ha
presa poco 10 l'europa intera l'oceano
artico ne ha 14 milioni sotto vari da
3.000 a 4.000 metri di acqua tanto così
per sorridere e io non so nuotare
questo è il bello come in questo caso
non ha un grande senso che uno che non
sa nuotare e dentro l'oceano artico per
attraversare da un blocco di banchisa ad
un altro trainando sì la slitta però
questo è un altro tassello che va bene
anche aggiungere quello che voglio un po
raccontarvi è che tutto anche queste
paure vengono in parte soppresse da
questo raggiungimento del tuo scopo
finale questo fa sempre parte di quel se
vogliamo sempre di quella soppressione
della paura noi immaginiamo questo
oceano
artico tutto bello piatto in realtà non
è così
avete visto si possono aprire si può
aprire la banchisa dalle correnti marine
però le stesse correnti marine fanno sì
che la banchisa venga cavalcata una
sopra l'altra blocchi blocchi blocchi
fino 4 5 10 metri di altezza e li devi
sempre oltrepassare e poi arriviamo al
nostro carissimo renato chi più chi meno
nella nostra vita tutti hanno avuto
momenti di paure particolare di momenti
in cui ci sono stati siamo stati segnati
da eventi e quindi anche condizionati
poi in vita adulta
però
con le dovute cautele c'è sempre un
sistema un modo per se vogliamo come
dicevo prima in parte assecondarla
oppure in parte possiamo quasi cambiare
se vogliamo personalità cioè cercare di
fregare la paura
renato zero in una canzone la favola mia
e appunto racconta questo è in parte mi
ci vedo perché io sono partito nel
lontano 98 con l'idea di attraversare le
varie distese glaciali di solo ghiaccio
però in realtà mi sono trovato ad
attraversare distese di mare che non
erano da me calcolate grazie